welcome aboard and prepare to set sail
with the greatest pirates in the
caribbean
time to go
dead man's chest is the second
installment in the wildly successful
pirates of the caribbean franchise and a
lot went down behind the scenes from the
crazy stunts and many challenges of
filming on location to the awesome
visual effects that made pirate legends
a reality given the fact that i'm you
know playing a man who has a beard that
can play the organ pulling off the
iconic monstrosity that is davy jones
required an equally unique approach to
the visual effects industrial light and
magics john noll and his crew invented
an entirely new process for doing motion
capture which allowed actor bill nike to
perform the role on set with the rest of
the cast instead of by himself on an
empty blue screen sound stage nol and
his team were then able to build davey
jones and his tentacles completely off
of naihu's spectacular performance with
all his little quirks included and yet
not so fortunate is to find lander
the terrifying kraken wasn't initially
very scary for the actors on the set
probably because director gore verbinski
was standing in for it he's like you
know be afraid i'm a tentacle and you
ah but eventually the legendary sea
monster was brought to life through a
mix of both practical and visual effects
in the scene where the cracking crushes
the ship the crew used a combination of
explosives and two huge pipes filled
with thirty thousand pounds of cement to
pull off the actual crushing and
afterward replace them with the cg
tentacles in the final cut i don't think
it's cracking anyways
always heard it says breaking making a
movie in the caribbean is a bit tougher
than you might think the entire crew had
to get all their shots in order to
travel to the tropical film location i
hate shots i really do
i don't like needles the production
filmed in saint vincent the exumas the
grand bahamas and the tiny island of
dominica where they dealt with
torrential downpours and extreme heat
and humidity they also happened to be
shooting during one of the biggest
hurricane seasons on record choppy
waters forced them to shut down
countless times and at one point the
entire production had to evacuate in
order to avoid hurricane wilma i can't
help it if your standards are lacked you
smell funny jack
a lot goes into the look of a character
as interesting as jack sparrow jack's
gold teeth were bonded onto johnny
depp's real ones by a dentist before
filming began however some of the gold
teeth in the back are actually real
replacements a couple of these are mine
these ones towards the backer
belong to me depp got the idea of having
different things in his hair from
rolling stones guitarist keith richards
who was a huge inspiration for the
character another notable accessory
sparrow's stripe sash from the first
movie had actually been lost so the
wardrobe department tracked down the
mountain villagers in turkey who wove
the original and had them churn out
another 100 yards of the sash
molecule
if you think jack's normal look is wild
wait till you see his get up as the god
of a cannibal tribe sparrow's clever
face paint design was an idea that gore
verbinski and the makeup team came up
with on the day of the scene however the
toe necklace was depp's idea and was
molded and sculpted from spare materials
on set sparrow's fluffy scepter was
actually a prop that was brought to set
by a visiting friend of depths who ended
up making two more for the production
you do know will taught me how to handle
a sword
having missed out on sword fights in the
first film kira knightley made up for it
by getting all the sword fights she
could handle in dead man's chest nightly
took to the sword very quickly never
failing to get the choreography on the
first try not only did she pretty much
do all elizabeth's sword fights herself
she also outdated her fellow castmates
and even earned the respect of the stunt
team
[Music]
easily one of the more creative sword
fights ever filmed the three-way duel
started on the disney lot where the
stunt team worked out the choreography
and a metal wheel fashioned with hidden
handles and handrails on set the wheel
was rigged to a truck and pulled through
the jungle with the actors harnessed
inside as awesome as it looked the
actors did not recommend the experience
when it came time for jack sparrow's
fateful showdown with the kraken some
elements were a little more real than
others specifically the monsters
spit
the spit in question was made of
concentrated sailing and blown out of a
bucket by an industrial sized fan onto
poor mr death after it had been tested
on his stand-in of course you can safely
assume it wasn't death's favorite gag
the foulness of just
living in it
if there was ever a scene that could
outweird a three-way sword fight in a
rolling wheel the bone cage sequence
might have pulled it off in order to get
some authentic performances the actors
were strapped in and literally rolled
down a hill
swung from a crane
and at one point gore verbinski had them
carry the cage and run with it
themselves this is the last day in
dominica and gorge is trying to punish
us
that's what it is the actors may have
had a rough day but the dummies had it
even worse
[Music]
when it comes to filming locations for
pirates the more obscure the better
verbinski and cinematographer darius
wolfski found tita gorge while looking
through a dominica tourist brochure and
thought it would be the perfect spot to
end the bone cage chase actors and crew
filmed while in freezing cold water that
was several feet deep and they had to
literally swim to location including the
67 year old actor who played cotton
david bailey the pirate life isn't easy
huh funny way to get to the office huh
who'd have guessed that the open ocean
would be so hard to shoot on while the
crew had particular trouble getting
boats to stay in place so gorfinsky
could get the shots he wanted you know
right when you line it up everything
moves everything we're going to the
fishing boat constantly in flux with
four background boats and numerous
floating light rigs to keep in place in
moving water it was a big challenge to
get everything in frame one shoot knight
went 17 hours without getting a single
take this again went to another level of
filmmaking for the filming of the sword
fight on a tiny little sandbar in the
middle of the ocean all the crew and
equipment still needed to be nearby that
meant putting the entire production on a
barge with a 20-minute boat ride to and
from set it was no cakewalk for the
actors either the sand there was super
wet thanks to the tide making it very
difficult to run and fight across the
beach for take after take after take
there's no one there
johnny depp stayed in character even
when he flubbed his lines and much like
jack sparrow dev was the source of
numerous comical moments on set at one
point he even forgot the name of the
notorious davy jones ship crocodile
machine or whatever it's called what's
the bloody thing called flying what
dutchman but he was also very helpful to
his fellow cast seems like it's always a
good time when jack sparrow's around
sorry
when it comes to a crew the size of a
small army you can never have enough
snacks actor jack davenport who played
the commodore james norrington was a bit
surprised to learn just how much of the
budget was going to the munchies i
remember saying to craft services chef
one day what is your budget for all this
he looked at me square in the eye and
said essentially unlimited i was like
what does that mean he was like i don't
know 2 million i was like for snacks and
he was like yeah safe to say no one went
hungry on this production
when the curse of the black pearl was
made there were no plans for any sequels
so while filming for her next movie
domino kira knightley chopped off her
actual hair for the part assuming she
wouldn't be reprising elizabeth swann
but when the sequels were announced
nightly had nothing for the pirates hair
and makeup team to work with so in dead
man's chest miss swan's long blocks are
in fact hair extensions
after rousing success of the first movie
disney decided to shoot the next two
films dead man's chest and at world's
end simultaneously that decision
resulted in production having over 200
shoot days in total though spending more
than half a year on set in the caribbean
sound like paradise or torture let us
know in the comments